hey you guys it's Friday and here we are
once again giving you our little daily
update yeah we're getting ready to
record the main show here in a few hours
yeah we're just checking in before all
that [ __ ] goes down yeah that's you know
that's what we were usually doing on
Friday night recording the show for
Tuesday yeah also I just put up the
review that we did have cat's eye I put
that up earlier today so hopefully you
guys are enjoying that or go watch it if
you haven't seen it yet let's see what
have I been doing today holy crap this
morning I didn't even get to go for my
damn walk this morning because I woke up
at 6:30 and it was like a [ __ ]
horrible thunderstorm yeah like as bad
as that one we had the other day where
we were all like tornado warnings and
they were telling us to like hide under
the bed yeah you know what I mean like I
kept getting all these notifications on
my phone like take cover take cover like
we didn't get hit by a tornado obviously
but they you know they had seen them in
the area so they kept like thoughts of
me but it was it was like that this
morning though and it was like that for
like an hour and a half is that - yeah
you just slept right through my house of
blow away I was be sitting asleep you
don't think over and fall asleep that
[ __ ] actually not so good pouring
down wind and lots of rain yeah it was
like the Green Ranger vertical like kind
of the windows and [ __ ] it's like a
freight train coming by the wall other
than that been a slow day [ __ ]
raining in [ __ ] yeah it's kinda Bend
rates is it still raining now I think I
feel like when I looked out the window a
little bit ago it was still raining yeah
it's like we've been working on you know
I've been doing like research for the
show we're gonna do and just you know
general other kind of [ __ ] also we
watched what do we watch last night
watch that Korean movie is pretty good
yeah they just put it on shutter it was
called zero point zero megahertz I think
yeah it's like a Korean like paranormal
ghost type of movie of paranormal
investigators and ghost possession
Korean ghosts kind of um but they kind
of generic but it'd make good move even
their generic movies
they're good you know they're I don't
know they don't piss you off or anything
you just sit there and drink and watch
me like yeah you know they got kind of
likeable characters this wasn't you know
this wasn't one that really like stood
out but it it wasn't bad either yeah it
was kind of just like a you know pretty
standard dinner movie ghost movie yeah
like some paranormal investigators that
go to this haunted place or whatever um
also oh I should say if you have shudder
and you're into Joe Bob Briggs you know
you should know on shudder he has his
show the last drive-in and he does like
these really long you know movie things
like they they'll show like hours and
hours and hours of movies and then like
in-between like he'll talk about him and
[ __ ] so apparently they're doing a new
one tonight and it's gonna be live
tonight but then they're gonna you know
they archive them later because I
watched like his Christmas wanted his
Halloween one hunch it and he's doing
they told him that he could do a 24-hour
marathon and it could be whatever theme
he wanted like you know for everybody
that's like just stuck at home and stuff
so he decided to do 24 hours of redneck
joy he's doing he's doing Gator bait
he's doing Smokey and the Bandit he's
doing Slingblade he's doing like this
there's a list like on some I think it
was on the AV club's blog cuz they
interviewed him about it and they have
like a list of all the movies that he's
gonna do like it's just he's crazy like
this so like a couple of like you know
good movies in there too but most more
like kind of like these really like
sleazy like B movies like all about
rednecks and stuff I think he's doing
Tucker Dale vs. evil too and there but
yeah it's like 24 hours I think it
starts tonight at 9:00 if I'm not
mistaken and like I said you can watch
it live but then they'll like archive it
later on so you know if you're not doing
anything on this particular night and
you have shudder and you want to like
watch 24 hours of redneck movies with
tricks which actually I kind of want I
mean some of the movies they're showing
like you know I've seen them before but
it sounded like a good time but uh
that's probably all that was going on
yesterday in the damn apocalypse yeah
what else people were saying
Tom you got first world problems [ __ ]
I'm for [ __ ] now I grew up halfway
between Mississippi and Brazil Sao Paulo
Brazil I'm a product of a damn third
world is no way Mississippi's first
world that's third world look at Brazil
man damn back in the 80s
[ __ ] was [ __ ] wild man yeah yeah it
was like a Duran Duran video she Duran
Duran videos were like super slick and
like yeah I was talking about like
hungry like the wolf [ __ ] you know the
big picture you're on back to elephants
is you there's nothing back there
there's no elephants in Brazil I rode an
elephant once yeah at Circus World
anybody from Central Florida remember
that old theme park circus world I went
there when I was a little kid that was
like terrifying like writing because I
was just like a little girl so it seemed
like I was on top of a [ __ ]
skyscraper
like on this [ __ ] stinky elephant you
know I was like yes they had like a
little cage thing that's so you couldn't
fall off yeah unless you're worried
about getting off into this Bitcoin look
at Bitcoin why I want Bitcoin wallet
yeah I mean like more than one way of
paying things like I'm gonna I'm gonna
investigate how to use Bitcoin okay
crypto currencies and [ __ ] some people
are making money in it but you know I
just I just would like to have something
you know [ __ ] another way of paying
for things you know I mean that might be
interesting yeah yeah yeah and see what
the bit I am just researching it I'm
just looking at it I also like the way
it looks it's like a round took a coin
or you could really get like a real
Bitcoin is I think it might be just
costume jewelry but it's like probably
it's probably being [ __ ] calm Italian
with book and some yeah exactly
it looks like it's worth even more than
money yes [ __ ] bitcoin one bitcoins
like $7,000
okay yeah yeah we're gonna be like but
they're [ __ ] around with it you know
and I was trying to you know in a while
I thought that was like a long time ago
but they're still using it it's a way of
getting away from banks yeah you know I
mean you can take some of your dollars
and put them in Bitcoin and then you got
like another account that's outside of
banks I never buy [ __ ] with that that's
kind of cool too yeah yeah I know how it
works I just you know I don't know
that's like I said I feel like the
heyday I don't really hear that many
people talking about it anymore
yeah but you know yeah that way if a
[ __ ] bank gets a wild hare it's a
habit SAS says no you can't buy that cuz
you know or whatever you can't yeah then
you know I mean you just pay for it in
[ __ ] Bitcoin good like trade for it
and possibly ads right my drugs is [ __ ]
I think that's what people are using it
for like illegal purchase nice yeah
purses they don't wear out porn and [ __ ]
like that yeah who knows maybe but
that's not what I imagine that that's
not really what most people are yeah for
I mean I don't know but that's what I
was well there most of making money on
it
yeah you can make money with it but I
just want to learn more about it okay I
think it's the future evidently when
like what what country was that was at
Norway or one of those Scandinavian
countries they kicked out all their
[ __ ] banks for all the [ __ ] they
were doing to the people and it was
replaced with an app that was kind of
like Bitcoin and that country up there
doesn't really have any banks the survey
just uses this app with Iceland Iceland
or something like that something I can't
see out that I'm thinking that might be
the next thing to go is some of these
banks yeah so I kind of want to get my
foot in something other than banks and I
think bitcoins the ones been around long
you know the longest yeah that way
there's tons of other ones but that's
kind of like but that way of banks and
credit cards start to [ __ ] collapse
from this [ __ ] chicanery that they're
playing here and there's some stuff
going on with a Federal Reserve Bank and
there's there's just a bunch of fishy
[ __ ] habitant with the economy they're
seeing like the money markets
and I think it'd be a good idea to just
like have a [ __ ] and online
independent baking or a way of paying
for things online you know that doesn't
doesn't doesn't need any banks yeah it's
just running off an algorithm yeah
pretty interesting you know which that's
all money does anyway it's all fiat
currency well nowadays yeah that's all
it is yeah so why not I don't know if
anybody out there [ __ ] with Bitcoin man
flick a drop a drop something in the
comment section yeah yeah I might hit
that Bitcoin wallet okay yeah you can do
whatever stuck with it yeah put some
money in okay so uh what else do we have
started anything yeah cuz I wanted to
kind of keep it short because we do have
should we gotta do well and we have to
like record a really long show tonight
yeah I don't want to like lose my voice
and [ __ ] because I have to have you
record some other [ __ ] too like some
ghost stories I'm not I got that little
electronic terminal for the end to the
lights to string these lights together
but I don't know if I'll [ __ ] with that
because we're gonna do this the show
soon I mean you might have to you can
probably do it over the weekend sometime
yeah I did actually get I got my memory
upgrade the RAM upgrade yeah how's that
work yeah it's I don't know what's you
know no difference yet not really I mean
[ __ ] has been like programs and stuff
been like opening quicker and right like
that
let's see if it affects our ability to
record it better frame rates and stuff
did you change anything no I didn't well
we'll know if there's any improvement in
quality just with this video when it
goes up yeah well I don't have this on
the maximum setting so it's probably
just gonna look the same yeah but it may
not it may look better even though I
mean like like I said you know that's
gonna be just helping me do things quite
like things will save faster like
there's just more you know what I mean
but yeah I got that it was actually
really easy to install I didn't think
that it was going to come till the end
of the
but it came yesterday okay so I
unscrewed the Mack I was like scared
that I was gonna mess something up
nothing there I didn't know and that's
the biggest one now right
that was big like because this laptop is
old that's from 2008 and you can only as
far as I know you can only go up to
eight gigs it comes with four but if you
you take the two it's like two little
things right so before it had like a -
like two - gig cards in there I took
both those out then I put two four gig
cards in there so now I have eight but I
read somewhere because I was looking
because they have 16 gigs - but they
said it won't work on on a computer that
old no good you know what I mean so
there might be another way no I'm just
saying 8 gig is as much as I can get you
do it came with four that might be
enough yeah it's a ram right yeah okay I
mean you know so it's not really storage
space that's operating space for the
programs yeah yeah so that's what I'm
saying so I wanted like something that
was like would speed things up because
might cuz my [ __ ] is guy cuz I work on
like really big files like really big
video files audio files you know I have
I have these complicated board games and
stuff about the storage memories or
nothing there do you have any idea how
big that having the memory is yeah well
I don't know like I don't I don't really
know offhand you know what I mean but my
dad increased that - yeah well I could I
have other [ __ ] for that I could get
like another I have like little hard
drives and yeah crap like that extra
many stuff yeah but I mean I have one of
those and I could get another one
they're only $40.00 okay um but I forgot
what I was saying but well clearly it
doesn't matter because just now that was
asking questions you're saying nevermind
yeah cuz I forgot what was - yeah see I
wasn't - we're getting old yes I don't
save before if I don't say it
immediately I'll forget - same thing
with you you forgot yeah I did forget
yeah brain performance all [ __ ] up
well not really because I mean I would
have remembered and if you gotten like
but she didn't remember bust it in and
you were to remember okay 20 years ago
you would have remembered
if I busted in or not I didn't know you
twenty years ago I know that but I'm
just saying your brain functions that
have been better I don't know about that
yeah we're gonna have to get you another
brain like an external brain in a jar
like when the science fiction movies
yeah I could get one I could just it
could ride around on my shoulder and I
could just like plug it in when we're
about this doctor brain [ __ ] what about
the PC you think we can upgrade that
thing probably I'm not worried about
that one as much as this one because
this one's much older yeah okay um so
and this is the one that I do most of my
like graphic design and like you know
shadows we're not running in any
limitations on the other one yet no no
not really I mean the biggest problem
that I have with the PC is not so much
memory it's that [ __ ] Windows 10 and
Google Chrome don't like to play very
well together
so I usually get so it'll usually crash
like five or six times a day because
Chrome makes it crash and I can't and
I've tried like every little fix that's
supposed to like make it not do that and
nothing has worked so far and I'm like
[ __ ] you I'm not using Bing so I'm not
using like another I don't want to use
Internet Explorer I don't want to use
like other cuz all my shits in Chrome
you know so all right well we don't need
to be boring them anymore but about our
problems well [ __ ] if we talk about our
plans and stuff what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is there to do it's okay I got some
drinks coming tonight we'll do a show
yeah show on cannibalism Donner Party
and all that [ __ ] yeah well you gotta
you just ruin the sprite yeah there now
there no till Tuesday right I won't know
till Tuesday yeah well the patrons will
know on we only have about 200 people
regularly listen in any way to these
early things that's true it's not just
it's not just good it's just our heart
it's just other stuff safe yeah cuz
nobody else cares about the bad way all
right so uh we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow stay safe out there